Google Club Dax 2017 has hosted a lot of
talks detailing the future of clouds if
you didn't get a chance to catch Rob
craft introduction to machine learning
and stay tuned because here's the recap
[Music]
Eric Schmidt describes machine learning
as the next transformation of technology
the programming paradigm is changing
instead of programming a computer you
teach a computer to learn something and
it does what you want
that's important because 90% of the
world's data is unstructured it doesn't
say hey I'm a picture of Rados cat on a
cat shelf we just have a picture it
turns out that most people on the
internet don't usually label things with
what they actually are so our challenge
is to drive unstructured data into
structured understanding once you've got
structured data you can provide value on
top of it in order to achieve that you
need a few important things like good
quality clean data which is really hard
75% of the workload for machine learning
data scientists is doing data modeling
to get that clean data the remaining
effort is in algorithms to apply to that
data the machine learning process takes
in data that comes in and applies an
algorithm against it to generate
predictions that connect the rest of
your business processes now chances are
that the algorithm isn't quite right or
the data wasn't clean enough or you
don't have enough data you will turn
these weird scenarios into something
that you operationalize using
specialists focusing on data cleansing
and different algorithm types for some
of these things you don't really need to
stay on the cutting edge you can use
someone else's black boxes and focus
your own team on specialized systems
where you've got unique IP to lend
against it in practice and Google offers
tools across the spectrum to help you
firstly there's tensorflow
powerful flexible open source sort of
frameworks that allow you to create your
own set of systems with exactly the same
code that we use internally the bad news
is that it still requires you to write
the ML equivalent of machine code and
tensorflow is largely meant to advance
the science but it also in many cases is
completely sufficient for production use
next is cloud ml engine this automates
the most painful parts of tensorflow
you can let us decide if you need 64 GP
and if you need 12 of those in the US or
14 in Asia
how many SSDI oopps per second you need
and how long you'll likely meet it we
currently support t-shirt sizing your
environment in small medium and large
which means uh you know I wanted
eventually or it's a trivial problem or
it's a reasonable problem and I want it
reasonably quickly and I'm willing to
pay for it or I really want it now and I
don't care how hard the problem is
finally there is the black box section
with pre trained models for translation
vision and video but in the near future
we expect to have a solution that slots
in here between the final two options
where you can add the capability to
identify something specific using your
own data set and this is just the tip of
the iceberg if you'd like more details
on that you should check out the full
video and if you want more recaps on
great next content make sure to check
out the rest of our playlist and don't
forget the next world tour coming
through into a city near you
[Music]